a new week brings no fresh start no end
to this suffering just another challenge
of survival
kharkiv faced more bombardment overnight
russian forces stepped up heavy shelling
in cities across the country
president zielenski has expressed anger
at what he called silence from western
leaders as russia said its strikes would
continue
we will not forgive the shooting of
unarmed people the destruction of our
infrastructure we will not forgive
hundreds and hundreds of victims
thousands and thousands of sufferings
instead of forgiveness there will be a
day of judgment
tough words and harsh sanctions have
done nothing to deter vladimir putin
in a phone call with his turkish
counterpart the russian president said
the fighting would continue until
moscow's demands are met
and so the inhumanity continues to
efforts to evacuate 200 000 people from
the port city of mariopol have failed
for a second day most people here
sleeping underground after a week of
almost constant shelling
one and a half million people have now
fled the country in just 12 days
brave souls fleeing for their lives like
this 11 year old who traveled by train
to slovakia on his own
arriving with a small bag and a
telephone number written on his hand
his mother has thanked slovakian
authorities
there's a nuclear power plant next to my
town
which the russians are shooting at it
was on fire i can't leave my mother she
can't move independently so i sent my
son alone on a train towards the slovak
border there he met people with a big
heart your small country has people with
big hearts please save our ukrainian
children and give them a safe haven
the world is watching this war unfold in
horror
with a third round of talks between
russia and ukraine expected later
the need for a breakthrough grows ever
urgent
sally lockwood sky news